not many of you then
with three olympic gold medals and 31
major goals in total adam peaty has been
untouchable in the pool for seven years
his book is written but he's nowhere
near finished not until project immortal
is complete
project immortal for me was again doing
a time that no one could ever achieve
so for me
i my world record is 50 56 88 i went a
little bit slower in tokyo than that
obviously that wasn't my intentions but
with covid with the travel with
everything that got in our way i'm very
happy with that time but this next three
years is how we achieve project immortal
having broken world records 14 times
across the 50 meters and 100 meters
breaststroke he says the key to his
success is anger
redness for me is almost
that is my super strength i can go and
use anger to the empty degree i can use
it to push through barriers that no one
else can push through
i don't know where i get it from it's
just almost manipulated like a fight or
flight response it's got to be war
you've got to treat it like they're
going to take something from you because
they are
so i'm not going to sugarcoat it because
there is no sugar coating to do this is
how i am this is how i perform and that
you know requires cutting my competitors
off and completely challenging myself
into
absolute performance
winning gold in tokyo was his biggest
ever challenge not because of the
competition but rather the lack of it
due to covid
going into 2021 olympics that was tough
that was very tough because my mindset
was geared up for last year
and so i had a lot more pressure
a lot more relief when it actually paid
off um
but it also cost me a lot it cost me a
lot to get there in terms of motivation
in terms of my commitment i was
questioning why am i doing it and i
never ever question it i'm like this is
what i do that's what i love but when
you've been doing it for so long without
any gratitude or validation from
performance such as winning gold medals
because we didn't do it for a whole year
that's when it starts to question you
and that was a tough thing that really
the toughest thing was beating myself
that year was it a bit sad once you'd
won um and i know there's nothing anyone
can do about it the fact that there was
no one there to watch it well thank god
for tv
but um yeah i mean it was because no one
can share that moment that timeless
moment with you uh your close friends
your close families fans
fellow teammates they're the only ones
that could see it so yeah i mean
i mean but at the end of the day there's
nothing you could have done about it
there's not a shoulda woulda coulda
there's not a moment you could have
changed and i'm just grateful it went
ahead because if it didn't if it
happened that that year would have been
i think done forever so i'm glad the
moment went ahead and i still i was able
to create something and inspire people
he took a three-month break after the
olympics and swapped the pool for the
dance floor on strictly it was different
it was different normally i walk out in
a pair of budget smugglers
i'm walking out on a tight leotard so
it's similar yeah
similar very similar and i like i'm
missing my fake tan i've still got a bit
of ram here but
yeah it was good it was an amazing
experience because it pushed me up my
comfort zone so far what about the
future how much more do you want to
achieve obviously paris is on the cards
and then hopefully if we get what we
want there la 2028 and uh
if i can do what i do it there both of
them
that i mean this i'm already living my
childhood dream so i don't even know
what that would be that's my that's my
man dream
now a dad to baby george he hopes he's
not a swimmer
you naturally want to push them to
football golf tennis um
but i mean if he wants to be a swimmer
he's never going to beat my times so
if he's reading this if he's listen to
this in 10 years go on son um but
it will take everything your social life
your soul your heart absolutely
everything because if you don't give
everything
it won't pay off
and yet he's willing to push for seven
more years to complete project immortal
jackie beltrau sky news
you